[Music]
this morning on the dish inspired by his
father's cooking as a child chef Fabio
trabocchi got a fast start on a culinary
career born on Italy's Audrey otic Coast
he got his first job while still in high
school at h h at age eight sixteen
eventually at a top restaurant in milan
two years later he was a sous-chef
and by 20 a chef de cuisine after
working in London and New York he found
a home in the Washington DC area and a
big following the chef and his wife and
business partner have opened five
restaurants including the most recent
the spectacular Del Mar featuring
specialties of his wife's native Spain
chef Fabio bouquet welcome to the dish
and we were talking about this before
but we think this may win the award for
the most spectacular table remember an
above all stunning thank you thank you
so much tell us what we've got well this
is all of our family affair our middle
cross bridge between Spain and Italy
my wife fish is from Spain we just open
a Spanish restaurant so we tend to be
blending our cuisine a lot this is our
fire which is reassuring of the MARTA
seafood buyer with langoustine lobsters
mussels and calamari we have an heirloom
variety of letters from Trevizo Italy
which is in are called Acosta franco and
rosa de Gorizia it's a light touch to
eat with a pie itself that's how we
blend the Italian culture with Spanish
cuisine and Italian cuisine then we have
a pasta that is toasted with Parmesan
Reggiano in a parmigiano-reggiano wheel
well top with Parmesan Reggiano finish
so that we keep the Spanish touch with
the jamon iberico which is the world's
best ham out of kaboom we would be
remiss if we did not mention this
cocktail in the most stunning cocktail
glass I've ever seen what's in here so
this is one of the cocktail that we're
featuring at the morrow Spanish
restaurant it's made with and it's a gin
and tonic gin and we're doing and this
gene is jean-marie which actually has
the flavors of olives there's a tiny
firm of Olives over the top and our own
house-made tonic that's the best present
at Genentech I've ever seen I want to
live
let's let's first speak of your
upbringing on the Adriatic coast how did
you come your father was a big influence
here father was a defining influence II
didn't even know about it you know it's
an Italian man the Lord's food and his
way of living is surrounded by what
we're gonna eat today and how much we're
going to prepare for tomorrow he started
as a farmer it started as a farmer and
he didn't know it was give me an
education take me as a young kid to be
strolled from farm to farm and meet his
friends and you know choose tomatoes and
choose uzuki Nia and she's got the
chokes and things of this that's how I
exposed to food you know by 14 you
wanted to go to culinary school yes I
enjoy SIEM cooking and I want to be the
same like any young man would look at
his father and what he does yeah he
wasn't a chef it was a self-taught chef
yeah he just enjoy cooking over the
weekend and he were artists ingredients
from farmers we never went to grocery so
everything to us was extremely natural
and beautiful and delicious and all that
and I was like you can imagine from a
big family meal on Sunday it would be
taking three or four hours going over
you know everything that we prepared and
where it comes from and having also the
conversation around the dining table
yeah with this wonderful food that was
the first source of inspirations for me
what was it like spending your teenage
years in the kitchen now I mean you
started very young very young 14 years
old is when I started I started in the
kitchen I started washing dishes I
started cleaning a parking lot of the
restaurant because I don't know how much
they will trust me with everything
around yeah yeah yeah but those that
were the very beginning of my career and
I loved it I loved it because I was part
of the grown-ups I could be you know
into a work environment I can get to see
people enjoying their meals and and all
of that so that was that was the
beginning of the career and I want to
leap ahead a little bit but but this is
this whole family connection you have
made sure you've instilled in your two
children it is a very important that
that connection carries on for me and my
wife so our children our and our part of
our business today and they we are a
family affair when it comes to our
restaurant let's look at your son we're
looking at there my son is
it's part you know it's been exposed to
our cooking and they both know how to
cook my daughter she's 16 my son is 14
and they can arrange themselves a good
lunch or a good dinner or prepare me
breakfast that's the motive chef as I
ask you to sign this dish which is
custom on the program absolutely if you
could it is such an incredible table if
you could share the bounty of this table
with anyone past or present who would
you pay there will be my father so you
got to see the seeds they planted and
enjoy with our family today what a
harvest chef Fabio trabocchi
congratulations on all your success I'm
from Washington
I love the restaurants thank you open
more please for more on Schechter both
you and the dish head to our website at
CBS this morning calm